dann stellen sie sich vor sie sind
dieser hölle endlich entronnen lassen
ihre zerbombter heimat zurück sie
erreichen endlich ein sicheres land und
bekommen sogar eine unterkunft nur um
dann noch einmal durch die hölle gehen
zu müssen das ist jetzt einer
18-jährigen geflüchteten ukrainerin in
düsseldorf passiert auf diesem hotel
schiff wurde sie von den behörden auf
dem rhein ein quartier tja und dann
passierte das also die ersten nächte
dort und auf diesem hotel schiff oskar
wild das also in diesen tagen als
flüchtlingsunterkunft fungiert ist diese
frau 18 jahre alt vergewaltigt worden
von anderen flüchtlingen von zwei
männern irakischer herkunft und
nigerianischer herkunft die beiden
männer mitte dreißig haben also diese
junge ukrainerin dort offenbar
missbraucht
vergewaltigt auf diesem hotel schiff
dieser flüchtlingsunterkunft und es
wirft die frage auf auch in diesen tagen
wer sind die menschen die auch kommen
aus der ukraine
auch dieser frage werden wir uns widmen
heute bei bild live angesichts dieses
dramatischen falls dort in düsseldorf in
dieser flüchtlingsunterkunft